I'm trying it out and see what happens.
Before it was a -3, 2, 5, 7, and now the first position is completely unchanged.
I'll explain to you in a second why.
The third one went from 5 to 5.5, and the landmark went down from 7 to 6.8.
Graphically, this guy becomes larger than 5, and this landmark even shifts a little bit
to the left to make these two things closer together than they were before
when they had a separation distance of 2.
Now this picture doesn't really explain it well, because it's a 2D picture,
but in 1D that's exactly what's happening.
Also interesting is the initial position is unchanged.
These are the correct answers.
Now, I would be blown away if you guessed them correctly.
The reason why the initial position doesn't change is the only information we have
about the absolute coordinate location is the very first initial position anchor
that we said was to be -3.
None of the relative rubber bands change the fact that we need this guy to be -3.
A relative change between these 2 things over here
means the rubber band is different, but it's a relative thing.
This is the only absolute constraint we put in.
Clearly the absolute location of the first position doesn't change.
The reason why becomes larger than 5 is--well, think about rubber bands.
Our landmark is around 7. We believe to be at position 5 in the noise-free case.
We just put a tighter rubber band between them. It's not 2 anymore; it's now 1.
That means we are inclined to move the landmark and this position closer together.
That's exactly what happens.
If you go to this solution over here, the final position becomes 5.5. It's now 5.5.
The landmark becomes 6.875 instead of 7.
Now, this is the case where the rubber bands don't add up.
This is one of the places where Graph Slam is just magical.
Before everything added up, but we have cycles in these structures.
These cycles might not added up, because we have noise and motion,
noise and measurements
What our method does by computing this thing--omega to -1 times xi--
we find the best solution to the relaxation of those rubber bands.
That, to me, is sheer magic.